[Musique]
que s'est il passé ce 29 mai 2020 nous
sommes à boca chica au texas quelques
minutes avant l'explosion sur un site
que space x avait envisagé au départ
comme une zone de lancement des fusées
parce que c'est très au sud c'est près
de l'équateur
et puis space x s'est ravisé pour des
raisons d'efficacité le sol de la zone
notamment est trop instable ou pour
organiser des décollages et donc c'est
devenu une zone de test spécifique
hélas le 29 mai 2020 et sixt est
justement le prototype starship et ce n
4 pour serial number 4 numéros de série
4 alors il faut préciser tout de suite
que cela n'a rien à voir avec le
lancement de la capsule crew dragonne
qui a lieu à quelques jours d'intervalle
et c'est aussi pour ça que je fais cette
vidéo c'est pour vous dire que nous
allons suivre cet événement en direct
sur figaro live et je vous invite à le
suivre en direct commenté en français
sur la chaîne youtube figaro live sur le
site du figaro je serai pas tout seul
des vrais spécialistes avec moi pour
répondre à vos commentaires à vos
questions pourra dialoguer pendant
plusieurs heures de direct ça va être
super n'hésitez pas à mettre reminder
pour ne pas le rater et recevoir la
notification dès que la démarche c'est
quand même une première pour ce pays 6
un vol habité vers la station spatiale
internationale
retour au projet star chips avec ça
space x veux préparer l'avenir et
envisager des voyages plus lointain que
les seize direction la lune me mars
seulement voilà avant d'y arriver on en
est encore aux phases de test
apparemment l' incendie serait dû à une
fuite de carburant
bon comme on peut le voir le feu était
assez vite maîtrisé a forcément les
conditions de sécurité sont là il faut
savoir que c'est le quatrième prototype
du coup sm4 que space x père duran duran
des tests au mois d'avril au tout début
du mois d'avril
c'est starship sm3 nous précédents
prototypes qui en avait fait les frais
lors de tests de pression
et puis à ce sujet il faut savoir que le
nas que le patron célèbre de space x
avait déclaré récemment le 26 mai dans
un peu de caste vouloir recentrer les
activités de space x vers les vols
habités et c'est ce dont je parlais
précédemment dans la vidéo bien
évidemment si vous voulez suivre ce
direct avec nous il y a le lien dont la
description
[Musique]